oh my god this like demon monster child
what did I get myself into I used to
babysit a lot in high school to earn
some extra money and over the summers
but this was my very first job in
college it was my very first time
babysitting for one of my professors
kids and he had three kids it was two
older girls they were in like first
grade and third grade and then one baby
who was around 12 months old they were
super sweet kids and I could tell it was
gonna be like a pretty good night they
were fun and well-behaved so the parents
left and the kids had a couple bedrooms
we were playing in the bedrooms and then
all of a sudden I swear it happened and
like half of a second the baby somehow
ended up in his room by himself he shut
the door and pushed in the lock so I was
freaking out internally because I didn't
want to scare the kids cuz he was
obviously a baby - you can't leave them
alone me and the two girls were talking
to the baby through the door we were
trying to tell him how open the door but
of course he didn't understand so while
the baby was locked in the room I
thought a lot about whether or not I
should call the parents whether or not I
should even call the police or something
but the baby was fine he wasn't freaking
out and I felt like he was saved and I
really didn't want to bother the parents
like they got a babysitter for a reason
and they want like a night out so I'm
like looking all around the house for
the key I'm like looking for stuff to
try to pick this lock I'm asking the two
other kids if they know how to open the
door of course they don't they're
convinced that he's gonna like starve
alone in this bedroom but they like run
to get Cheerios and they're like sliding
them underneath the door it feels like
it's been a long time but it's probably
only been like a couple of minutes while
they were pushing Cheerios under the
door I was thinking oh my god he could
choke on this and I couldn't get to him
in time and even if I called the police
they still wouldn't be able to get here
in time so I was freaking out like just
picturing like the worst-case scenario
even though it was his room it was baby
proof the windows were locked he's 12
months old he can't open a window but I
was just like thinking of all these like
crazy scenarios like
get himself into while he was alone
eventually I found a key somehow and I
unlocked the door he was fine all the
kids were fine and the night went on
kids went to bed great so this whole
ordeal felt like it lasted for hours but
honestly the baby was probably only in
the room for maybe ten minutes and it
was totally fine in the end
then the parents were coming home and I
was super super nervous I didn't know
whether I should tell them what happened
or not because like the baby was fine
like I could just not tell them and then
it wouldn't even matter but I decided to
be honest I told them what happened they
were just like oh yeah he's learned how
to do that recently it's been happening
a lot and I was like okay like thanks
for letting me know thanks for doing me
where the key was thanks for explaining
how to get him out of the room but
anyway it was all fine however they
never asked me to babysit again so that
was the end of that job my first
babysitting job I was fourteen years old
and I was everything for a neighbor
around the corner for two little boys
Vinny who was six and Mark who was nine
and it's supposed to be just like a
simple like let's try you out while I go
to work not far away so it wasn't like
any kind of like overnight saying so I
anticipated it being kind of light like
a few hours slice up some apples you
know hang out plate kick some ball in
the backyard what ended up happening is
the mother told me that the
nine-year-old mark in fact was kind of
pissed because she told him that he
could not go to a friend's house he had
to stay home Wow I watched them when she
went to work and he was not happy that
she told him no and so she informed me
hey FYI mark might have a bad attitude
because he wants to go to his friend
Tyler's house you just tell him no he's
not allowed to go he has to stay here
with you I was like you got it and so
when I was like hey kids what's like
what do you wanna do I wanna play some
game when I color when I'm like watch
movie mark was like I'm going to Tyler's
house I don't care
this kid spoke like that and
I was like no you're not no you're not
you're not leaving and then he proceeded
to storm into the kitchen opened a
drawer pulled out a huge knife and
replied to me what are you gonna do
about it you two 14-year old me and so I
was like whoa I didn't know this friend
hang was so serious
of course I'm terrified and shocked and
insulted he's holding the knife and he's
already faced and I was like okay just
like calm down this is not a big deal
don't tell me what to do because I was a
new babysitter so he's like who's this
[ __ ] like you know it's like he doesn't
know me his mom put me in charge his
character being so enraged was like I
want to do this thing and she's telling
me I can't but who is she and so I'm
terrified because he has this very real
sharp knife like 20 feet away from me
and his little brother his six-year-old
brother is just in the other room kind
of watching all this happened and so I
was like timeout just take a breather
and I called my mom because I didn't
know else to do was my first babysitting
job and she was horrified because she
trusted that our neighbor this mother
would be putting her daughter into a
safe situation watching her children but
in fact that was not what happened my
mom told me
I'm gonna call Mark's mother and you're
gonna leave and I was like I can't leave
these kids she's like yes you can
you're not safe there you can walk home
and so she called Mark's mother who to
an astonishing reply was very casually
said I was waiting for a day when he
would do something like this and my mom
was like what the if you knew that why
would you let my daughter babysit she's
like oh like not something like this but
just like he's just yeah he's got issues
I left at like great before his mom I
pulled in the driveway
so I think he like kind of quarantined
himself in his bedroom and like slammed
the door and put on some kind of loud
music or something my father was not
pleased with this he went over to their
house and basically threatened this
young child which I don't think was a
good idea and said like don't ever come
near my daughter again and all the stuff
and this tough little kid was like I
don't know they exchanged words my
father exchanged words was like a ten
year old everything was fine
at like my safety was fine their parents
took care of them I later found out that
Mark told his father who then broke the
back window of my dad's car so luckily
everyone was okay but it was really
weird and scary and I never went back to
that house ever again and went on to
babysit lovely children in the future
and drove by with caution every time
after
[Music]